when William McKinley became the
president of the United States in 1897
he presided over a country that was
getting a little bit upset
what was it upset about well it was the
island to its South Cuba which at this
point was a Spanish colony and was also
rebelling against said Spanish rule this
rebellion kicked off in 1895 and had
some pretty unfortunate timing
I mean rebellions are always pretty
badly time for those being rebelled
against but it coincided with the
spectacular rise in American nationalism
when these ideas were combined with the
stories about Spanish cruelties in Cuba
the American people got upset as such
the people in the press wanted to do
something about it but McKinley wasn't
too keen it wasn't until the Spanish
ambassador's criticisms of McKinley were
made public that he opted to send a
warship the USS Maine to Cuba in order
to protect American interests in
February 1898 whilst in Havana Harbor
the Maine exploded in a respective of
what the cause of the explosion was the
American people wanted blood so bad was
the public fervor and pressure from
opponent ala Tisha's that McKinley new
war couldn't be avoided and so one April
the 21st 1898 America did just that and
declared war on Spain under the slogan
of remember the Maine
to hell with Spain now Spain knew it
wasn't going to defeat the United States
in a war but chose to fight it anyway
why well there were two main reasons the
first was that Cuba along with the also
revolting Philippines were the last
major vestiges of the once glorious
Spanish Empire and the second reason was
that the dishonor of immediately
surrendering to the US was too much for
Spain to bear his leaders preferred to
go down fighting and lose with its honor
intact so how did said fighting go it
went amazingly well for America you see
America opted to fight the war on two
fronts one in the south in Cuba and one
in the east or to the west technically
in the Philippines this was where
Commodore George Dewey decisively
defeated the Spanish fleet there at the
Battle of Manila Bay the US Army then
landed and brought over the exiled
Filipino revolutionary Emilio Aguinaldo
who promptly declared Filipino
independence to bring the Philippines
back into the fold the Spanish launched
a major fleet hoping to dislodge the
Americans it was shortly after this that
the u.s. captured Guam and by captured I
mean they turned up and gave off a
warning shot now traditionally when
nations were at peace they would fire
off a salute to each other
the Spanish garrison there didn't have
any ammunition so the governor who
didn't know he was at war promptly
apologized for not returning the salute
the island was captured with no fighting
as for the Caribbean theater the US
started by seizing some place in
southern Cuba called Guantanamo Bay it
later landed an expedition
force here and pushed inland the Spanish
retreated but were extremely adept at
defensive tactics and so American
progress was slow until the primary
American force landed on July the 1st
this was the force that contained the
famous Rough Riders volunteer army led
by a certain Theodore Roosevelt the
Americans advanced inland and fought a
small Spanish force at the infamous
Battle of San Juan Hill here the Spanish
were able to inflict many more
casualties and the Americans than they
themself suffered before retreating and
Acacia wandering it was this battle that
made Theodore Roosevelt a household name
July the 3rd saw the largest naval
battle of the war the Battle of Santiago
de Cuba during which the Americans
obliterated the Spanish fleet there it
was after this that the aforementioned
relief force that was being sent to the
Philippines was promptly turned around
because the Spanish coast now lay
undefended Puerto Rico or Puerto Rico
was invaded in late July but Spanish
forces there were incredibly difficult
to dislodge by mid-august the Americans
had captured Santiago the second largest
city in Cuba and in the Philippines the
Spanish governor had surrendered as well
with their forces on the run a much of
their Navy sitting at the bottom of the
ocean the Spanish stood for peace before
the Americans could march on Havana in
December a peace treaty was signed in
which Spain lost Guam the Philippines in
Puerto Rico to the United States Cuba
became a US Protectorate until 1902 when
it gained its independence in conclusion
the war had gone exceptionally well for
America which is why the Secretary of
State John Hay called it a splendid
little war America's naval prowess were
made clear to the world it not a great
deal of soldiers died in combat of
course lots of soldiers died from
disease but since yellow fever didn't
wear a Spanish uniform they didn't count
and for Spain the soldiers who fought on
Cuba and the Philippines had shown
themselves as being some of the best in
the world but of course the shock to
Spanish society for losing the colony of
Cuba was absolutely massive the Spanish
Empire was dead the American Empire was
born I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with extra thanks
to these patrons you can see on screen
for their continued support and an extra
special thanks to James Bissonnette
David archaeologists as ARCA Flash Danny
Maloney party-boy Koch coolin Castleman
Rob Waterhouse Chris wicker
Gustav Swann David Silverman Winston
Cawood Christian checky Maggie packs
Kowski Lexi Schwinn Anthony Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell Ike spinning
three plates are on the white and
Michael Reynolds